ألف: أرنب يجري يلعب يأكل جز رًا كي لا يتعب
باء: بطة نطت نطة وقعت ضَحَكت منها القطة
وقعت ضَحَكت منها القطة
تاء: تاج فوق الراس فيه الذهب وفيه الماس
ثاء: ثعلب صاد دجاجة وهو ماكر وقت الحاجة
وهو ماكر وقت الحاجة
جيم: جمل في الصحراء مِثل سفينة فوق الماء
حاء: حج أسمى رغبة فيه طوّاف حول الكعبة
فيه طوّاف حول الكعبة
خاء: خُبز عند البائع لا يأكله إلاّ الجائع
دال: ديك حسن الصوت قام يؤذن فوق البيت
قام يؤذن فوق البيت
ذال: ذئب وحش صَعبٌ لا يرهبه إلاّ الكلب
راء: رجل عرف الدّين فهو صدوق وهو أمين
فهو صدوق وهو أمين
زاي : زهرة أصفر أحمر هي بعيني أجمل منظر
سين: ساعة تحفظ وقتي في مدرستي أو في بيتي
في مدرستي أو في بيتي
شين: شمس فيها سرور فيها الدّفء وفيها النور
صاد: صائد ألقى الشّبكة بعد قليل صاد السمكة
بعد قليل صاد السمكة
ضاء: ضابط يحمي وطني يحفظ أمني يرعى سكني
طاء: طفل أجمل طفل فهو نظيف حسن الشّكل
فهو نظيف حسن الشّكل
ظاء: ظِفر نظّفناه طال قليلا فقصصناه
عين: عينا تخشى الله تشهد خيرا في رضاه
تشهد خيرا في رضاه
غين: غار غار حراء فيه أنزل القرآن
فاء: فيل ذو أنياب وهو صديق يا أصحاب
وهو صديق يا أصحاب
قاف: قمر فيه منازل ومواقيت تهدّى السائل
كاف: كلب عاش جواري يحرس غنمي يحرس داري
يحرس غنمي يحرس داري
لام: لحم ينمو جسمي يكسو عظمي فيه أسمى
ميم: مسجد بيت الله فيه أؤدّي كلّ صلاة
فيه أؤدّي كلّ صلاة
نون: نهر نهر النّيل فهو كريم غير بخيل
هاء: هرم عال القمّة في  بنّيّاه رمز الهمّة
في  بنّيّاه رمز الهمّة
واو: وجه للإنسان فيه نور بالإيمان
ياء: يد ترسّم زهرة تبدع شكلاً تظهر فكرة
تبدع شكلاً تظهر فكرة